[Music]
welcome to the block what we got excuse
me excuse me thank you thank you so much
i'm so sorry i'm late
you ever had a dream one you'd be
willing to do anything for
wow
anna how's work are you still interning
for that lady executive assistant
anna music people have certain
expectations and my girls need to flow
freely
who does your hair know what
me aren't you tired of it all the stairs
you get
you want to be one of my girls yes this
game all the way from india
forget about where it's from let's focus
on where it's going
you're not tender headed are you ah i'll
be fine
clients where the stuff is magic
wow how's it feel people look at you
and they see somebody else and somehow
you become
more of yourself i can't fault you for
doing whatever it takes
to get where they keep trying to keep us
from getting
in a perfect world a woman would be able
to wear her hair
the way she wants to
the most haired girl she see trees
covered in black moss
and made herself away maybe the hair in
the tree was
enchanted
that is fun to think about
something bad has happened oh i'm aware
it wants to take over us
look i cannot die today okay i've been
in church like 15 years
uh hey girl
damn that took a turn
you